pleasure to be here as Lisa noted this
is a different kind of lecture from the
other ones in conceptual foundations
it's about one country but with a good
reason I think and that is that that
country plays a central role in
international politics and it is hard to
talk about any odd topics that you're
going to be discussing in the course of
this semester without some reference to
to the United States however because the
role of the United States is so charged
so controversial I want to begin by
turning to a distant and quiet period
when its role was vastly different and
that period that the episode that I'm
going to talk about a little bit by way
of introduction is the spanish-american
war about which I would hazard the guess
that few of you are experts so I have
provided you what I call a cheat sheet
about the spanish-american war that
tells you everything you need to know
about it
in order to understand American foreign
policy in a completely different time a
completely different time in which I'm
going to go through this very quickly a
new Republican administration comes in
there's an unprecedented attack on
American interests in its first year in
office
a group of defense intellectuals see
this is a big opportunity to turn
American foreign policy around two wars
result motivated by many different kinds
of foreign policy concerns among them
very intense concerns of a denial of
human rights in the countries that are
invaded there's a quick military victory
at the outset for the United States but
a strong insurgency develops
particularly in one of these countries
and the question that the United States
has to face is how to defend its
strategic
trysts without having to pay the price
of a long occupation this problem is you
can imagine becomes central to the next
presidential election but it has a
lasting impact on America's role now if
you've been paying attention at all you
get the joke right you can look at a
quiet time far in the past and see that
American foreign policy looks really
similar to the foreign policy of today
and at a time when the United States is
by far the dominant power in
international politics
so with that tantalizing introduction I
want to spend the rest of the time
talking about how to understand these
continuities in American foreign policy
over time and we're going to look at
three themes which I've put on the board
here that little part of the black board
that was allotted to me while the screen
was down and you were all indulging in
democracy the three topics are domestic
politics the goals of American foreign
policy and I'm going to look at two in
particular and I didn't write them down
because they're long but you can write
them down in your notebooks regime
change and democracy and section three
the exercise of American power now the
kinds of questions we're going to be
looking at are under domestic politics
who really controls American foreign
policy whose influence counts in the
second section what how do we understand
the stated goals of American policy
where do they what do they mean and how
are they balanced against other goals
and finally the exercise of American
power will be of particular interest to
those of you who know that the key terms
of this administration's foreign policy
have been words like unilateralism and
well in regime change so we're going to
we're going to be taking looking at
these problems in his store
perspective but I think in a way that
should illuminate both present and even
more this is a bowl boast that political
scientists and practitioners make the
future okay let's start with domestic
politics in American foreign policy now
merely to talk about domestic politics
is already to put up a red flag that
we're not approaching this subject in a
way that is completely standard for a
realist
outlook and I want to make a confession
to you at the very beginning of this
lecture and that is this my view of
realism my view of realism is and take
this down it tells you everything you
need to know about international
relations if you don't want to know very
much and I and is Exhibit A for this I
always liked to read aloud the entire
discussion in the large work by one of
our eminent realists John Mearsheimer
who you're reading this week in his book
the tragedy of great power politics his
entire description of America's cold war
policy and it goes like this don't think
you're going to be here for an hour only
the United States had sufficient
military power to prevent Soviet
hegemony after 1945 so American troops
remained in Europe throughout the Cold
War that's it that's the whole that's
all you need to know if you're John
Mearsheimer and a serious realist
America had the power needed to deter
hegemony stayed in Europe throughout the
Cold War you know we could dismiss the
class right now but if you want to know
more if you want to understand the
weirdness of American foreign policy its
contradictory character it's you know
what makes it so changeable so
mysterious you need to dig
little deeper and that's what we're
going to do here and I want to start
that by pointing out to you six
dualities about American foreign policy
that make you realize that there's more
going on in the excess in the conduct of
American foreign policy than John
Mearsheimer is one sentence might let me
lead you to believe
first of all duality number one America
has the most powerful military by far
and the most powerful tradition of
civilian control of the military and the
biggest cadre in the world of civil
civilian defense experts secondly it has
the most imperial presidency and the
most extensive congressional limitations
on presidential power third it has done
the most of any country of all countries
to create international law and
organization and is the most determined
to protect itself against unwanted
applications of international law and or
in the processes of international
organizations to itself fourth duality
America has what I would consider the
most ideas-driven foreign policy and at
the same time it is most readily and
cynically often taken in by anti
ideological pragmatic moderates or
authoritarians
elsewhere who present themselves as as
promising allies they're called our SOPs
the comment of a famous American policy
maker v the United States is the most
committed to free trade as an
ideological matter and very heavily
influenced by small protectionist
lobbies sixth it is deeply influenced
American foreign policies and deeply
influenced by business interests
and yet most likely to upset them by
pursuing other goals that don't serve
the interests of business so how to
explain all of these dualities well
together they paint a portrait of a
highly pluralist
policy process a process for the
influence of American foreign policy and
not all the participants in this process
are committed to the same goal but they
don't have to be and they don't have to
work out an agreement on the same goals
American foreign policy is additive
you've got a pluralist process and the
result is that most of the goals pursued
by the are men a great many of the goals
pursued by the participants in that
process are implemented and ducked and
pursue now I'm not the first to make
this discovery in fact there's a long
tradition of seeing Democratic foreign
policy an American foreign policy in
particular as disorderly ineffective
even defective John Maynard Keynes who
were reflected on his experience
negotiating with the United States over
international economic issues said that
the u.s. organs of government are quote
so incredibly inefficient one wonders
how decisions are ever reached at all
and Winston Churchill also a friend of
the United States said you can always
count on the Americans to do the right
thing after they've exhausted all the
alternatives
and it's not just foreigners who say
this this tradition of seeing American
pluralism as dysfunctional is is an old
one Walter Lippman a very famous
American public intellectual we used to
call them as said that the influence of
the American public and interest groups
on American foreign policy means that
American policy is alternately there's
his quote too little too late or too
long and too much too pacifist or too
bellicose to neutralist to appeasing to
intransigent
moreover commentators in this vein have
found Americans blind to their failings
George Kennan was one of the most
distinguished American diplomats and
diplomatic historians got sick of
diplomacy
he said history does not forgive us our
national mistakes because they are
explicable in terms of our domestic
politics a nation which excuses its own
failures by the sacred untouchable nosov
its own habits can excuse itself into
complete disaster so harsh words some
realists try to make sense of this
disorderliness and see the ways in which
american political institutions have
changed over time to produce better
results Fareed Zakaria I think one could
call a public intellectual too has went
before became one when he was a mere
political scientist wrote a book called
for wealth to power in which he talked
about how the wealth of the United
States and created potential power but
it's institutions weren't suited to the
effective exercise of foreign policy and
so he describes the way in which those
institutions were improved streamlined
centralized with greater resources
available for foreign policy with more
presidential control and that at the end
of his story this happened in the late
19th century and early 20th century at
the end of his story you've got an asset
of national institutions styled for a
realist ready to exercise power in the
world the way a realist would want the
only problem is the American people in
the American political process didn't
stick with that approach instead what do
you have right after the end of farid
story you have the reassertion of
congressional power challenging
overriding President Wilson and
virtually destroying his presidency by
refusing to ratify the treaty he
negotiated the Paris at the end of World
War one we see examples of the
manipulation of American foreign policy
in ways that outraged and confound
realists every day my favorite one is
the case of the Gulf Coast shrimp
farmers who were so alarmed by imports
of shrimp from Vietnam and Thailand that
they got the US government to declare
their shrimp a special a separate
species but you can any bet you Joe
Stiglitz and Jeff Sachs when they talk
certainly Joe Stiglitz are going to you
know echo this kind of this kind of
complaint but but pluralism extends far
beyond the manipulation of American
foreign policy by business interests in
the 1990s one of the biggest disputes
between the United States and the EU can
involve the so-called helms-burton Act
which was an American law which
essentially the purpose of which was to
get Europe to adopt America's policy
toward Cuba which Europe resisted and
the reason that the United States
Congress did this was because of the
decisive factor in it was the Cuban
American community and the electoral
votes of Florida I guess I should say
and it reflected the in fear the
influence on American foreign policy of
something that I would say is even
greater than business in general and
that's ethnicity this subject is often
commented on these days especially with
back to the American Jewish community
but and especially by foreign analysts
who don't understand American politics
very well but I think they often look at
it too narrowly my proposition for you
about the role of ethnicity in American
foreign policy is this any organized
American ethnic group usually gets the
policy at wants on the issue it cares
about if it is organized enough to care
and there are many examples of this that
one could give the failure of the
British government for example to
persuade the US government to stop the
flow of money and guns to Irish
terrorist groups you know our closest
ally asked us to crack down on terrorism
and what the United States going to do
said no you might think it had something
to do with ethnicity turkey another
close American ally has often found its
interests challenged by Armenian
Americans I'll tell you a story about a
conversation I had with Nancy Pelosi at
dinner about almost 10 years ago I had
just taken on a position at the in the
State Department where I was responsible
for Armenia and Azerbaijan and there by
someone who directed Turkey
and I said to her you know I'd like to
come and talk to you about section 907
which was a provision of US law that
banned aid to Azerbaijan because the
Armenian American community objected to
it and she looked at me
she's a congressman from California now
Speaker of the House and had represents
many Armenians in California and she
said you must have a lot of time on your
hands
what was she saying to me you can't talk
to me I do what I think serves the
interests of my constituents we don't
have a rational discussion on this coal
in the Cold War one country in Eastern
Europe had a special status in American
policy toward the Soviet bloc it got
trade credits assistance visits from
American presidents even at the height
of the Cold War and the reason for it
was this country's Poland was partly
strategic calculation and partly
domestic political calculation this
country was the first country to enter
NATO at the impact of the end of the
Cold War and I'll tell you national
strategy might have been enough to
create that result but if it hadn't been
enough might have happened anyway now
realists are critical of all such
influences I remember hearing John
Mearsheimer give a presentation in which
he said he was really glad the Cold War
was over because this would diminish the
influence of East European foreign
policy experts think remember that when
you read Mearsheimer in Walt today this
debate focuses on to Israel and it's
very appropriate that the critique of
the influence of Israel of the Israel
lobby is led by two of the most
influential realist experts on
international relations you will I wager
discuss this article in that is asked to
ask you to read in section and I hope
you'll use the very excellent review of
it by les Gelb in the Sunday Times last
week but let me add a few quick words
about it myself
to show you the significance of the fact
that Mir Sharon Walter realists not
experts on other things they are not
experts on American politics because
they don't seem to know that lobbies
focus on the
Congress above all else they don't
particularly want to understand the
influence of the lobbies on Congress
because they want it to be a little
weirder than that they want it to be
about Neo conservatives and evangelicals
exercising influence on the White House
not Democratic members of Congress who
are you know their meat and potatoes of
the work of any everyday lobbyist
secondly they're not experts on
ethnicity because they say were they
would know that the diasporas of of
American ethnic groups are always more
radical than those in the home and the
government and public opinion in the old
country
they're not experts on the Middle East
or experts on the evolution of American
foreign policy they're where do they
think the relationship with Israel came
from well they don't really tell you
much about that it comes in fact in a
really interesting way out of a Stratego
land ambitious policy effort by the
Kennedy administration to innovate where
they felt that the Eisenhower
administration had failed and to build
relations with the major all the major
powers of the Middle East Israel Egypt
Saudi Arabia those were going to be the
three pillars of policy and that failed
and the residue of it actually is the be
in the in the residue of that failure is
the American Israeli relationship now I
want to close this section you'll talk
more about Mearsheimer Walton section I
want to close this first part of my
lecture by focusing again on the
question of whether or not pluralism
tends to produce successful policy the
liberal answer to this liberal theorists
answer is yes the realist as I said
Creek I mentioned
and Churchill and Lippmann and Kenan is
not the realist that you're the Liberals
that you're reading or analysts of
liberal influences in American policy
include I can bury and mean and I can
bury makes an argument in after victory
about the open and penetrated character
of American democracy and which he says
it's a good thing it's good for foreign
powers to be able to influence American
policy why because it means that the
foreign policy of the largest power
reflects more interests than just its
own think about that
Walter Meade
who's a short article on Jacksonian ISM
you're going to read or a larger book
about this about all of the schools of
American foreign policy Jacksonian ism
is one of them but he discusses others
as well
Hamiltonian ISM focuses on trade will
Jeffersonian ISM which focuses on
keeping the military and and other
commitments of the United States abroad
small Jacksonian ISM which focuses on
honor and American power and Wilsonian
ISM which focuses on the spread of
democracy and he says that American
foreign policy is always a coalition of
schools never
there's never domination by one school
totally there's always a melding of
their interests and the result is a
stronger and more effective policy and I
think thinking about how well democracy
produces foreign policies one of the
issues challenges raised by any study of
American foreign policy on this I want
to give liberalism
I mean realism the last word however you
could argue that the pluralism of
American foreign policy is a kind of
indulgence a luxury that only a powerful
country can enjoy that less powerful
countries have to folk
Moron what their real priorities are
they can't pursue every interest groups
pet obsession pluralism has this
character of not requiring a priority
prioritization of among policy goals
failure however tends to shut down
pluralism to challenge the lack of
priorities and in to assert and to
elevate the role of realism in American
foreign policy we've seen one period
when the role of realism was really at
its peak and that was after the Vietnam
War maybe we will see that again that
would be one argument that you could
consider for the future of American
foreign policy now let me turn to the
second part of my lecture which is to
discussion of Americans goals for the
foreign policies of different countries
can be and looked very different because
of the particularities of history
culture geography economic development
military technology and so forth
what realism tries to do is to strip
foreign policies down to their
essentials to see regularities and
continuities but we've already seen a
challenge to realism in the process by
which foreign policy has been made in
the United States it seems as though
American foreign policy is the product
of pluralism now I want to take this a
step further does this lead does this
process lead to distinctive goals are
there discs Eric turistic goals of
American foreign policy that we can
identify and here I want to look at the
particular goals of the Bush
administration that have excited the
most debate over the past several years
and those were were regime change and
democracy the Bush administration made
the argument that the threat faced by
the United States and other countries in
in the two cases where it went to war
in that is Afghanistan and Iraq that
that threat was directly related to the
character of the regime ruling those
countries and that the right kind of
internal transformation moreover would
solve the problem but they didn't limit
this analysis to Afghanistan and in Iran
they extended it to the entire Middle
East they they saw obstacles to
agreement between Israel and the
Palestinians for example that had to do
with the character of the political
structure of the Palestinian Authority
this the nature of the threat that they
saw from Iran had to do with the fact
that it was a theocracy a theocratic
dictatorship is their view the the
promise that they saw in the democratic
transformation in Lebanon had to do with
this conviction that internal change
would produce the Democratic Change
would produce positive foreign policy
results and they had the same view
although you hear a little less about
that these days about Egypt and Saudi
Arabia moreover I'd go beyond this and
say there this view was not restricted
to the Middle East it's the way in which
this administration viewed its problems
with North Korea but it's the nature of
its relations with China and Russia I
don't want to overstate this the policy
of the United States is not always to
promote regime change in an active way
and certainly not always by military
means but the analysis of what's wrong
in America's relations with another
country when those relations are bad and
when there are problems generally kin is
based on an analysis of the internal
regime of that country
it explains and and generally the
solution is seen to be democratic
transformation this explains why there's
so many comparisons made
between George Bush and Woodrow Wilson
and it's important to understand that
care the nature of this connection
Woodrow Wilson is now generally regarded
as the most influential American
president of the 20th century foreign
policy terms someone who shaped the
American outlook on the world a source
of inspiration I'll come back to this in
a moment not only for George Bush but
for Bill Clinton and the core idea of
wilsonian ISM is conversion its origins
go well beyond Wilson
Walter Mead in his description of the
Wilsonian school in American foreign
policy sees the founders of this school
not as Woodrow Wilson himself but as a
19th century American missionaries now
the irony is that Woodrow Wilson himself
is generally seen as a president with a
failed foreign policy and maybe that
irony won't surprise so many people
who've studied the record of the Bush
administration but there and there's an
implication of the for the Bush
administration that is this approach was
not really suited this is what many
academic theorists would say not suited
to the real world leaders who pursue it
for a while end up having to give it up
and certainly in a successor American
administration is likely to drop it
that's a common view it's possible that
this episode of real intense fascination
with democratic transformation in other
countries as a solution to American
foreign policy problems it may be that
that will pass but I want to argue
against it I want to argue that we're
likely to see the persistence of this
approach with admittedly with fits and
starts retreats and advances and I give
you as the text to bear in mind here
that comment by a famous Columbia
historian Richard Hofstadter who said
our fate as
is not to have ideologies but to be one
what he meant was that the idea of
improving the world by remaking it in
America's image is not just embedded in
American values but in American foreign
policy I think it's easy to make this
case at least on a superficial level if
you look at the history of the past 60
years containment which was supposed to
be a realist strategy after all saw as
its goal what the internal
transformation of the Soviet regime it
was announced by Harry Truman in the
first step that he took toward it was
what was called the Truman Doctrine
which said that it must be the
commitment of the United States as a
universal matter to assist countries
being threatened by armed communist
insurgency John Kennedy carried this
further he said that the United States
would pay any price support any friend
bear any burden remember you you know
you've heard you were born too late but
you know that rhetoric pay any price and
bear any burden to do what you know the
sentence does finish at the end of the
sentence he says to assure the survival
and the success of Liberty
moreover throughout the Cold War the
NATO alliance which was the key American
instrument power instrument was seen as
an alliance of democracies and at the
end of the Cold War it was seen to have
succeeded because it was an alliance of
democracies and let me tell you that the
vocabulary of the presidents who who
came after the end of the Cold War the
first George Bush and Bill Clinton
picked up these theme in a very very
strong way that would make you think
some of their statements were those of
the current administration Bill
Clinton's vocabulary whether he was
talking about globalization
or genocide in Balkans was very much
about regime change and democratization
so the interest in Wilson predates Bush
and is it's the story that American
foreign policy makers have told
themselves for a long time about what
they're doing by the way you you may be
interested in a really quite
sophisticated historical a bit of this
history that is in a speech by defense
secretary Bob gates you may find this
hard to believe but two weeks ago Bob
Gates gave a speech at William and Mary
a historical look at American foreign
policy in the place of democracy in it
you'll find it on their website WWF NC
gov go to click on speeches and you'll
find September 17th really interesting
speech now there are two objections that
get raised when people say you know the
United States is committed to the spread
of democracy and to the ideology you
know to end-uses
democratic democratizing rhetoric one is
let's take let's think about these
objections for a little bit first that
it's just a kind of point-scoring
against adversaries that it's not really
sincere that's true in a way but what
you should understand is that it turns
out to be very effective point-scoring
and American policymakers internalize
the effectiveness of it moreover they
were prepared to pursue it in ways that
weren't always what they what were
intent what was intended Ronald Reagan
probably raised this kind of rhetoric to
a new level in the early 80s but the
first government that was brought down
as a consequence of this rhetoric was
that of an ally President Marcos in the
Philippines
secondly second objection to this idea
that democracy is part of the genetic
code of American foreign policy is this
isn't it always really subordinated to
other goals in the end you know when the
United States has to choose
between this goal and other more
practical ones in a military security
economic well-being it always chooses
the other yes also true one would not
want to deny the rich history I referred
to it earlier when I use the phrase our
SOPs of pragmatism and cynicism in
American foreign policy but I think even
so you should not underestimate its
staying power I think it's hard to
understand the evolution even in Iraq of
American policy without seeing the
commitment of the administration and the
analytical conviction to the idea that
making an internal transformation work
was the test of success what's the
what's the test of success that even the
president's opponents except in in Iraq
political reconciliation is to say
internal transformation is the solution
to foreign policy problems and I think
that's a consensus that over many
decades has spanned the political
spectrum you might give you one further
data point ask yourselves why John Kerry
spent so much time during the night 2004
presidential campaign ragging on the
Saudi royal family because the idea of a
monarchy as a as an appropriate Ally for
the United States that the United States
could count on is prima facie suspect in
American political rhetoric let me
conclude this session section by giving
this question of ideological goals a
little comparative perspective I would
not want to suggest that the United
States is alone in pursuing ideological
goals you see other countries doing the
same thing whether their secular goals
like revolutionary France or both
of ik Russia or religious goals have in
mind Iran since the Shah but also 19th
century Britain which often had a kind
of low Church agenda for its foreign
policy that led it to a moralistic
opposition to human rights abuses in the
Balkans and that's why Tony Blair's
policies in the Balkans and in Iraq have
to be seen as part of a long historical
tradition in British foreign policy
before they became poodles of the United
States but note this important
difference between the United States and
the other some of the other countries
that I've mentioned revolutionary powers
are usually most committed to the export
of ideology in the immediate aftermath
of a revolution generally there's a loss
of zeal and enthusiasm over time the
policy makers of diplomats representing
that country discover that it's kind of
inconvenient to have to pursue those
goals in relations with other countries
which generally don't like to hear about
your religious goals or your ideological
fervor and so they take the sharp edges
off they lose a real commitment to those
goals they favor a traditional security
or economic agenda they adjust to the
international environment they get with
the program now I think American the
American evolution has been almost the
opposite our founders were very prudent
men the you may know a quote from Tom
Paine revolutionary polemicist who said
that our relations America's relations
with Europe will always be positive as
long as eating is the practice of Europe
by which he meant we'll sell them grain
and they won't give us any trouble ok
over time American policy has become
more ideological so that the United
States now 200 years after its
revolution is seen as a revisionist
power why is that
let me conclude here by giving the last
word to constructivism dominant powers
need a set of concepts that help to
preserve the system they have built you
all know the terms soft power soft power
is a constructivist idea it means
getting others to want what you want it
legitimizes your goals
it's the realist policies shortcut to
accommodation with other with other
countries American foreign policy has
long been premise taun the idea that
having other countries become democratic
is the most effective way to increase
the soft power of the United States and
I believe it will continue to reflect
that belief okay
let me turn then to the third question
that was suggested to me at least by
their comparison between contemporary
American foreign policy and the
spanish-american war and that is the
exercise of American power how it's done
how the u.s. views --is its enormous
capabilities whether its economic power
military power this is related to but
still separate from the goals that it
pursues and it's been one of the most
discussed questions of international
politics in recent years not just among
academics but in public forums by the
public at large and to do that to think
about present a model of how the United
States uses its power I want to start
with the picture that is provided for
you in the assignment that you have from
John ikenberry who provides the most
developed and interesting and
sophisticated historical analysis that
basically reflects not just his own
offenses and actually predate some of
the current controversies what is I can
Barry say about how the United States
since the Second World War has used its
power well here's here's what it is in a
nutshell
he says American leaders have sought
enduring cooperation with other
countries particularly the European
allies through a what he calls a
negotiated compact a deal and the deal
is the pledge of American commitment to
their security in exchange for a pledge
of restraint or in parallel with a
pledge of restraint a promise not to you
abuse American power which is so
dominant and could easily be abused and
he says the formula of American power is
to pledge to use power for others and
not in in ways that serve the interest
of the United States to be sure and at
the same time not to abuse it he says
the result of this is that American
power is regarded as legitimate because
it's subject to what he calls strategic
restraint this is a kind of core
principle of American foreign policy as
the sees it it's a formula for managing
American primacy and I understand that
Professor Luck is assigned an article a
couple of weeks down the road that is on
this same theme making hegemony work it
I can Mary's analysis of World War two
and the end of the Cold War is how to
make American primacy accepted and
effective over time he says this
principle is constitutional this compact
is negotiated compact has acquired what
he calls constitutional characteristics
meaning it's widely accepted by all the
parties to the compact
and it has it there's almost a
constitution of international politics
as he sees it and what that Constitution
does he says is two things it limits
returns to power and he increases
returns to institutions now what are
those those are somewhat abstract terms
what do they mean it means you don't
benefit by pushing others around even
better if you don't have to push others
around you have a consensual process in
which the United States is able to get
much of what it wants by playing by the
rules this is this extraordinary
construct consent and moderation are the
core of the relations between the United
States and less powerful countries as he
sees them as they developed over over
decades after the end of World War two
and among the many benefits to the
United States of this compact is that
others feel no need to create
counterweights to American power
remember I said the constructivists have
this idea that soft power having others
be Democrats means that the United
States doesn't have to use hard power as
much liberal analysis of how an orderly
international system that serves
American interest is created is through
this negotiated compact we don't abuse
our power we support you the United
States tells other countries and in
exchange our primacy is is accepted the
unite the other countries don't have to
balance or check the United States or
didn't because of their confidence that
American power would not be abused you
will read a similar argument with
interesting nuances by other analysts
and scholars I'd recommend you look at a
book by Evo dollar and Jim Lindsey
called America
bound book by Charles cup chin called
the end of the American era various
writings by William wolf forth they have
different views but a lot of them a lot
of them kind of have an analysis that
heads in this direction now they all
recommend an American policy that most
of us would argue makes sense for the
United States and for the rest of the
world it's a prudent responsible
farsighted means of managing a position
of premise but that those are our might
be our preferences but let's put our
preferences aside there's one problem
with this historical picture and that is
it's not very good history it isn't
really the whole story of how the Cold
War and the end of the Cold War unfolded
in fact I think there's not much basis
not much historical evidentiary basis
for the compact that he describes look
at the early Cold War look at the at his
telling of it is there any concrete
evidence of anybody of any Americans
saying to any European let's have this
negotiated compact I think there what
you see is an overwhelming US desire to
close off opportunities for Soviet
expansionism even if it means increased
tension risk risk to be born often by
American allies not by the United States
itself and increase confrontation in a
footnote I think I can vary quotes
George Kennan saying that the US goal is
to preserve current disparities of power
between itself and other countries
that's something that you will come
across those of you who study American
foreign policy in another famous
document signed by Dick Cheney American
policy in this period often overrules
allies that doesn't negotiate with them
it overrules them because their views
are often seen as retrograde poltica
and their political systems as
dysfunctional incidentally what's
particularly seen is retrograde about
them is there
Loney ilysm now when American policy
tries to get others involved in the at
the end of the coat at the beginning of
the Cold War at the end the Cold War and
afterwards it's because it believes they
won't do their part on their own the
Marshall Plan for example is a case in
which the United States seeks to get
others to plan so as to avoid dependency
on American assistance they see others
as helpless and taking American aid and
not following through to increase their
own defense capabilities or even their
own economic strength
so the real continuity of American
policy over many decades is a suspicion
that Europeans will not be able to
contribute very effectively to common
interests what do you see if you look at
European policy in this period you see a
preoccupation to guarantee that the
United States will not abandon that it
will use its power to defend them if
necessary the idea in the early Cold War
that the United States would abuse its
power oppress other countries hardly
occurs to anyone now I think you see
this same pattern if you look at the
later period the 80s and 90s which
Eikenberry also describes in his book at
the end of the Cold War at that time the
u.s. is particularly worried by the
European by the inability of its
European allies to act effectively
against common friends so its response
is to push the envelope to box allies in
so they have no choice but to go along
with American policy confident that
success will justify American
unilateralism and you see this approach
in three episodes that I've asked you to
that you'll read about in the article of
mine that I've asked you to read on
American maximalism you see it in the
American handling of the so-called Euro
Missile Crisis in the nineteen
ATS you see it in the American handling
of German reunification at the end of
the Cold War and you see it in the
Balkans crisis in the 90s where the
Clinton administration was dealing with
the genocide in in the breakup of the of
Yugoslavia now what were the conclusions
that American policymakers took away
from all of these cases I think they're
not what I can very says or they're not
only what I can bear says and maybe
there's a coexistence of these that one
has to understand in order to come to a
sophisticated complete understanding
first of all the conclusion was allies
cannot usually be counted on to help
effectively an American policy therefore
has to develop its own goals and pursue
them firmly in single-mindedly secondly
policies of this kind are generally
successful policies based on consensus
on bargaining are often so compromised
that they can't work and finally third
although allies cannot be counted on to
help they can be counted on to go along
after the fact and so the United States
tries to exercise leadership in a way
that does not create lasting antagonisms
very important so as to avoid conflict
and need for balancing as an expression
of these principles I would I would
refer you to a statement in George
Bush's State of the Union from the 2003
he said America's purpose is more than
to follow a process it is to achieve a
result what he's saying is he disagrees
that I can very he says if you pay too
much attention to process you won't get
the results you need he's meaning just
to I don't think he's read I can read
his book
just a wild guess is but his meaning and
I can bear his terms is it's risky to
agree to limit the returns to power it's
risky to increase the returns to
institutions you may get paralysis now
as I said this is true has been true of
others before the current administration
it was true I would argue conspicuously
and often infuriatingly for other
governments during the Clinton
administration
that's why Chancellor schrder who was
Chancellor of Germany in the late 90s
until recently complained of the Clinton
administration's policy of unilateralism
it's why my old boss secretary Albright
used to set other governments teeth on
edge when she spoke of America as the
indispensable nation and they always
used to quote her as saying that even
though she was herself only quoting
President Clinton it was easier to beat
up on her than on President Clinton but
it didn't the irritation did not stop
American policies from becoming more
ambitious during the 1990s it didn't
stop President Clinton from talking the
language of multilateralism but acting
differently why and why have other
presidents done the same thing well one
suggestion comes from two very
thoughtful American political scientists
Barry Posen and Andrew Ross in an
article the citation to which Hashem
will distribute to the class he if I ask
him nicely afterwards and they analyzed
American grand strategy and came to this
conclusion that administration's that
start with the goal of cooperative
security often get meaning multilateral
consensual negotiated compact style I
can bury foreign policies often get
pushed towards strategies that are more
like primacy
and the reason is that because they have
ambitious goals they see in frustration
with the results that they get by
working with others they see that the
only way to achieve them is to push as
hard as possible to overcome the
objections of others now today the
policies the problems that American
foreign policy faces are so broad and
the international uproar over American
unilateralism so deep-seated and so
angry that you can't ignore it and just
say well this is how the United States
always tries to get things done that
doesn't work so well and so it's a
legitimate question to ask how the
United States will respond in the future
given that its tradition is to push the
envelope of multilateralism and go
beyond it toward policies of primacy in
order to achieve remember President
Bush's line achieve a result not just
follow a process well I can't I don't
think it's it mean it's an interesting
question I can't speculate at length
about it but I would say you already as
an indication of where future
administration's will go you already
have the example of the adjustment made
by this administration you could say
that the Bush administration is taking
the advice of liberal international
theorists more seriously the advocates
of process and of consensus in
moderation they say that the only way
out of current difficulties that liberal
international theorists is to give
cooperative security more respect to
become better listeners of earlier
difficulties
they understand that undisguised
arrogance doesn't produce good results
if you're isolated you've got no real
choice but to follow this path right
well this is how the Bush administration
has adjusted to failure and it's
possible that a successor administration
will do only the same and may even push
this further we're likely to hear it's
quite possible that we'll hear more in
under future administration about an
Eikenberry style negotiated compact a
new deal between the United States and
countries around the world maybe but I
think the weight of historical evidence
is very large and needs to be taken into
account I would suggest to limits to
other factors that need to be taken into
account in predicting this adjustment
when one predicts that the United States
was by virtue of its bitter experience
in this decade going to become better a
better listener and a better team player
ID two things one bear in mind the
dynamic identified by Posen and Ross and
I've referred to earlier even
cooperative security strategies take can
take a lot of quote leadership to work
remember that's why American
administrations of the past were often
pushed against their own inclinations
toward primacy and American leaders of
the future will also tend to doubt that
others because they've internalized this
themselves they will doubt that others
working on their own can produce
workable lasting solutions if you want
an echo of this perspective I recommend
to you an article in today's New York
Times October 1 2007 by Roger Cohen who
talks about how to solve the problems of
climate change in the future and his
proposition is you will of course need a
policy of
in order to deal with this problem and
yet he also says in a very stunning last
paragraph he says multilateralism
without a global arbiter has been tried
what he means is I think he means the
United States has to play that extra
role the global arbiter knocks heads and
makes multilateralism work here's a
second reason to be doubtful about the
complete adjustment that you've that you
might expect in American foreign policy
a reversion to and I can very compact
and that has more to do I think with
American identity and with some of the
themes that I discussed earlier in the
nation hmm for better and worse America
is as close as we get today to among the
great powers to being a country with a
calling with a sense of mission
the president of France made an
interesting comment about a week ago in
which he was explaining why he found the
American example in the world so
inspiring and vigor rating and tracted
and he said he said essentially friend
the French and the Americans are the
only two countries that think in
universal terms well this is not a
lecture about French foreign policy but
what he's talking about that calling
that sense of mission on the part of
American leaders and policy makers is an
outgrowth of American history and of
domestic politics and it leads the
United States to use its power in ways
that its leaders and its people regard
as noble and at other times or
occasionally at the same time to use its
power in ways that others find
impossible to accept or even to
understand today that gap that will gap
of misunderstanding is very great we can
hope that it will be reduced but we have
to recognize the factors that produced
it in the first place they have been
present in American foreign policy for a
long time for most of the last century
some would argue for longer than that
remember the spanish-american war look
over the cheat sheet that I've given you
America is calling it's sense of mission
is not something new it's not confined
to one party for one presidency and is
highly unlikely to disappear soon thank
you
now I remember when I was sitting down
here in the front row watching the
lecturers in this course scorn in thea
in the half hour remaining which i
always ask them to leave but i always
thought it was one of the most
interesting parts of the of the class so
fire away yes
yeah speak up a little bit you don't
have two microphones on you yep
I'm sorry you didn't think it was strong
huh
yeah I do I sort of get the drift okay
yeah I got you I got you
well sorry um let me let me say this I
actually think it's a he's reviewing the
book and I haven't read the book to be
honest there's only so many 400 page
books on reading these days but I
compared it to the the article and I
think it's it's important you raised two
questions if I get you one is about the
especially dire consequences of the
American alliance with Israel the I said
that there are other lobbies that are
able to get their goals in American
foreign policy and some people might say
well those lobbies don't actually have
dire consequences but I would disagree
with you totally I think that the
ability of American ethnic groups to
shape an often veto American policy
toward its closest allies throughout the
Cold War would have to be considered a
pretty significant consequence so I
think you're not right if you if you
think that there's just something really
weirdly distinctive about this policy I
mean you know you probably are not aware
of this but the term the Israel lobby is
I think meant to be an evocation of a
very powerful lobby that was always
spoken of in
in kind of demonizing terms in the past
in American foreign policy that was
called the China Lobby and the idea was
that the China Lobby had kind of
dictated American policy in a in a very
dangerous way by creating a decades-long
estrangement between the United States
and communist China well you can go into
the historical you know how what really
produced that estrangement between
United States and kind of China and I
think it's the China lobbies role is not
quite what it is thought to be in
popular mythology but you certainly
couldn't say that that didn't have dire
consequences I mean this is just a
reality is that often these policies are
very very significant now I haven't seen
you mentioned the visit of the President
of Iran to Colombia last week about
which I've actually read a lot and if
you haven't been reading it well I just
urge you to get out there and and read
the popular press I you know the
Washington Post in The New York Times
and lots and lots of other media and if
they didn't catch all of the nuances of
what the speakers were saying you know
it seems to me it's incomplete to say
the very least to say that this shows
the power of the Israel lobby over the
American media I think it just shows the
defects of the American media if you
don't mind my saying so and I'll tell
you a little bit as an example of this
just a little proof of it I read a
couple of articles about what president
Bollinger said in introducing the
President of Iran and I thought man
that's strange and then I read his
statement and it struck me is really
very different from what was reported in
the in the media now I think you know he
probably should have anticipated that it
would be covered in the way that it was
but you know when the American media
failed to cover a problem perfectly
there are more parsimonious explanations
and looking for the influence of an
ethnic lobby now other comments yeah
well you're easily shocked but I like
this I like these sort of is the shocked
ability of cephus students
see this is this is why we have programs
to train people in international
politics is make them less easily shot
nan I'm teasing I'm teasing you here's
what I mean I mean it's a constructivist
idea in this sense that it's based on it
is based on ideas for one thing soft
power is a term that I believe it's a
brilliant term and it's a very important
concept in international politics and I
also think that my good friend Joe Nye
has done a lot to have people
misunderstand it you know that it's
based too much on movies and McDonald's
and all that
what soft power is is its legitimacy
that is it and he defines it this way
it's having people want what you want
and that gets you into a conceptual
range into conceptual territory where
it's the I it isn't just your ideas that
matter but it is I think their we're
talking about a construct a sort of set
of concepts that I think constructivists
actually explained better than than
liberals because liberals tend to focus
on institutions making things legitimate
and I think constructivists have a lot
to add in pointing us toward the ideas
that create legitimacy as well and I was
pointing toward an American idea that
democratization adds to soft power in a
way that I think has actually probably
been more important in the history of
American foreign policy than any number
of Arnold Schwarzenegger movies or any
number of Big Macs yes
well I'm saying that the democratization
is a goal that you can pursue lots of
different ways including through hard
power and what the Bush administration
has discovered is that you can get into
a lot of trouble with the pursuit of
this goal through hard hard power the
correction I mean in a way what a lot of
academic theorists have said to the Bush
administration is you don't get it you
know this is something that to be
effective to serve the interests that
you're talking about serving actually
can't be done in this way
it has to be more a goal served by soft
power but that's something one can you
know that that that you debate the
achievement of regime change is you know
many people have argued in Germany and
Japan sure wasn't achieved through soft
power now we've probably got some
questions over here yeah
well then you're good corrective to
these previous questions I don't I don't
want to I don't want to say that the
question is yeah well you weren't
bellowing as sufficiently because you're
right up at the front it's hard to
projector at the back the question is it
will in the future if American
policymakers adopt consensus and soft
power and a negotiated compact and an
Eikenberry approach you know
neoliberalism will that just be for show
and I you know I think it will depend on
who they are and what the issues are it
will I think it would be wrong to doubt
but in advance the sincerity of any
policy makers particularly when they're
going to want to be showing that they're
not the Bush administration and I think
any successor to to the Bush
administration is going to as Roger
Cohen says in the times today
try to benefit from the contrasts you
know new presidents tend to view that
did George Bush Senior when he took
office emphasized that he was you know
pursuing a kinder gentler America so you
hear that it and President Clinton
certainly said that he was going to be
different from from President Bush but
the real question isn't so much their
commitment to a certain kind of
multilateral consensual process and
there isn't there you know their
rhetoric it's
happens when the policy gets stalemated
and here I can't predict the future for
you so I'll just give you an example
from the past which is the Clinton
administration's handling of Bosnia
policy it came the Clinton ministration
came into office thinking that Bosnia
that the previous administration and the
Europeans had really screwed up Balkans
policy very badly and that there from
you know tolerating genocide and it
tried to come up with a new approach and
the Europeans shot it down they said no
we don't want that we don't want that we
don't want to get involved here and so
the clinton ministration back down and
things got worse and worse in the
balkans and it seemed as though genocide
was rafet repeat itself and at that
point they became very frustrated with a
multilateral process I'm sorry to give
you a too long story but it's important
to see how it how this can work it's not
that there was anything insincere about
the Clinton administration's approach to
this it's that the frustration level
when it saw other countries not reacting
in a serious way to dealing with a
serious problem that they essentially
decided we have to make our own policy
because they thought otherwise you're
not going to get any result now Mike
rather than a forecast I would have a
question what is it that American
policymakers will think when they find
when they rediscover the frustrations of
multilateral diplomacy well they may
have some of their sober advisors
telling them stick with it be patient
don't go there don't do what the Bush
administration did but some of them will
also say now is the time for a little
bit more muscle into this policy we've
got to indicate to people that this kind
of hopeless you know compromising of
results out of you know policies and
agreements so that they were totally
meaningless gives multilateralism a bad
and then you get you get people then you
will get policymakers saying things like
what President Bush said to the UN
General Assembly before invading Iraq he
said this issue is a test of this
institution I can easily imagine a very
angry American president giving a talk
like that about climate change you know
at a certain point there's going to be
no solution to climate no international
agreement on climate change that does
not involve a lot of very very tough
bargaining and will it always be done
with great you know consensual niceties
maybe not yeah it's me we vision yeah
the RS over the r sob problem is a
really it's a tough problem and you'll
you know I really urge you to read
secretary gates speech on this because
it's thoughtful and in good faith and
and he wrestles with this this problem
he because he says you know you just you
can't understand how America acts in the
world if you think it's just realism
with just idealism you know Pakistan
that's kind of an you know that's one
where first of all you have to
understand that the you know the council
being given by regional specialists is
oh my god you don't understand how bad
things could be if we leaned too hard on
the Pakistan ease with our heavy
breathing about democracy think how you
know
what awful outcomes could result if if
things get pushed too too hard the other
thing I'd add though about that is I
wouldn't take for granted that you know
everything that is said in American
Pakistani diplomacy you know there was a
time when advocates of pursuit of human
rights and democracy said it had to be
done through quiet diplomacy meaning
through dialogue with leaders that was
not in full public view and I I don't
know I got no insight inside a story
about about the American handling of
this problem over the past several
months et is there is no doubt that say
after September 11th
the American conviction which was really
across the political spectrum was that
the for time at least was that and
overvaluing stability had actually led
American in the Middle East had led
American policy in a bad direction that
it had you know led American
policymakers to be complacent about
relations with countries that were very
hostile to you know deeply hostile and
you know did that produce a
reorientation in the short term toward
Saudi Arabia answer absolutely not did
it lead to putting things on the agenda
in us-saudi relations that hadn't been
there before absolutely yes the same I
would say is true Egypt there's a the
you know the Bush administration was I
think overconfident for a while about
how much you could achieve just with
rhetoric
it hasn't totally backed down I talked
to friends who were an embassy Cairo
they say you know we everybody they say
every American journalist Twitter and
pundit will tell you that the United
States has backed away totally from the
democracy agenda in Egypt and he said
you know we spend all of our time out
there on this account so it's a it is a
very it's a complicated problem and I
you know did not want to oversimplify it
with any glib formulations and if I you
know went too much one direction or the
other I don't want to I don't want to
mislead you it is nevertheless a part of
the American policy mindset that I think
makes it impossible to ignore American
policy unless you really keep it front
and center
yeah do you think that also in democracy
promotion is embedded in American
foreign policy do you think that will be
enough failures of that policy to you
know so that it will cease to exist but
I don't mean to be flippant but it seems
that when we force democracy on
countries that we occupy that that
democracy doesn't I mean what countries
become Democratic our policies are
negative to those countries then should
enter public expresses they're in both
anti-american people into power I mean
what do we do
will there ever be enough failures to
discourage Americans from thinking that
this is an important part of American
policy no for two for two reasons one
there will always be contrary cases
where it looks as though internal
transformation has produced a huge new
set of benefits and opportunities for
the United States I mean the collapse of
the Soviet Union and the Soviet bloc is
sort of principal in a case of that you
had the collapse of a regime that was an
ideological grounds hostile to the
United States and it seemed to remake
the world and not only that it's so
inspiring to Americans when you know you
have these large crowds in the streets
and they're you know invoking American
authorities and figures and marching
around with you know the Statue of the
Statue of Liberty
will there ever be enough failures if
there are examples of success like that
of course not
and but I would say the other reason is
you know American policies often quite
resistance to failure to learning and I
don't mean that in a completely flippant
way on
mean that these goals are understood to
be long-term goals and so you don't
necessarily pull back entirely from you
know one or two setbacks I mean I just
think this is a issue that will be will
never be pursued in a in a 100 percent
leave everything else a sideway or go
down to zero that's just not not
thinkable in American foreign policy
well you had a few had a question
anybody over in this side of the room
yeah
no I mean catapulting off the world
stage no you could I suppose you'd argue
that American influence at the end of
this story has been reduced in ways that
you know are important to understand and
thinking about the future of of American
policy but what's in what I think is
really important is that you shouldn't
just view either of these episodes in
power terms that is a challenge to
American power resulting from the you
know the sinking of the Maine and of Ann
Arbor the burning structure that I refer
to in the chi-chi and you know and the
exploitation of that or the response by
the United States in a way that
increases its power and that's all you
need to know about it and that doesn't
tell you that story it doesn't tell you
what the mix of preoccupations and
domestic concerns and legitimacy were
that surrounded the the war effort for
that you really need to dig in a little
deeper understand you know my
predecessor see if it was a
distinguished American diplomat named
Warren Zimmerman who wrote a history of
American involvement in the
spanish-american war which is called
first great triumph it's really a good
book that you can skip the first half
which is all the you know charming
personality portraits and read the
second half but the second half is a
fascinating portrait of the policy
process and how Americans who've been
strategists pursued strategic goals in a
a domestic political context where the
main rhetoric was about human rights you
know the the spanish-american war was
probably the episode that really
elevated American human rights concerns
to the top of American foreign policy
which is something that very few people
know and an ambassador Zimmermann
describes it in a in a brilliant way
more questions over on that side of the
room yeah you and then in the
suit-and-tie yeah
well partly because the editors of the
journal told me they don't give me 6,000
word and partly because I don't know as
much about that and partly because it is
oh it's a less perfect case Oh political
interpretation you know as often that
base that on that but what I do say is
that it's important then that you thank
you for for asking the question is that
the the Kay the policy German
reunification was pursued absolutely to
the max to to person to achieve all
American goals there was absolutely
nothing left out there was no equivalent
of you know calling the war off after a
hundred hours and the Gulf War was a
different case which remained
controversial in American policy circles
partly because it had been called off
early and in that way it represents a
kind of contrast to the other policies
that I said
more maximalist its and then of course
there's a long following story the by by
saying it was called up early by the way
I don't mean the US Army didn't March to
Baghdad because there are many things
that American policymakers advocated
doing nobody wanted to go to Baghdad
short of that if you want to read a
really good book on the Persian Gulf War
there's a another book by journalists by
it's called the generals war by trainer
and sorry trainer and Gordon it's really
fabulous book and particularly the first
50 pages in the last 50 pages on the
evolution of American policy yeah
last question and will be dismissed at 7
o'clock
well you you've you raised a good a
really good question because generally
the debate about American democracy
promotion involves the question of
acceptance of non-democratic regimes and
a less focus on democratic processes
that produce difficult contrary
sometimes very undesirable policy
results I wouldn't say that it's it's
exactly true of American policy that it
does not recognize democracy in those in
those cases something that I think with
there's actually been a rather sober
realization on the part of American
policymakers that this can be what you
get and the response tends to be it
divides interestingly you have those
people who say well this is what you get
and that's why democratic processes are
really just - you know we're playing
with fire you shouldn't do it and that
would be that's a sort of realist view
that you know we can't afford to
encourage democracy because too many
Democrats are hostile to the United
States you get a second view which is
hold on a second that's the
first phase of of democracy and we ought
to have the courage of our convictions
that in time in a democratic peace
Theory produces regimes that will be
more friendly toward other democracies I
had a conversation once that I'll
describe to you even at the risk of
going two minutes over with the current
president and Prime Minister of Turkey
before he was Prime Minister mr. Ayer
Dewan who would come to Washington and
had a round table with a small number of
people and I said to him look how do you
react to the debate in America about
promoting democracy in the Middle East
when a lot of people say that if you had
a an election in Saudi Arabia it would
produce that the winner would be a sama
bin Laden and he gave a very thoughtful
and interesting answer I thought which
is something that you know American
policymakers have to wrestle with he
said you should definitely understand
that if you have a democratic process in
the Middle East that it will not be won
by came five it will be who was king at
the time I think he said that's not it
you're not going to there's nothing that
you can do no Constitution no electoral
rules no nothing that will lead the
people of Saudi Arabia to vote in the
king and if the choice is between the
king and Osama bin Laden then that's
what you'll get but he said that's not
democracy democracy in no country
produces those two candidates and the
real the interesting process that you
have to ask yourselves about in in a
country like Saudi Arabia or he was you
know obviously had Turkey in mind is
what does what a democratic political
norms do to the
people who participated in politics who
become the contestants who in Saudi
Arabia really would be the candidates
for president if it weren't the king and
Osama bin Laden well that's an
interesting question and if you you know
to get there you have to envision these
countries several phases of historical
development further down the road than
most of them are then most of them are
now and you have to envision political
actors who learn the lesson of Hamas is
success in Hezbollah success and figure
out what do we have to offer that's
better than and that's that's the answer
to the long term answer to the question
about how American policymakers could
think about democracy in the Middle East
as a continuing objective because you're
absolutely right if if if that is a goal
the only reward for which is to you know
produce Osama bin Laden significant
policy advance does it thank you very
much
you